uh we'll be advice you would give some
kids that are skating they're 12 13 15
they're just skating enjoying it but
they maybe they want to figure out like
try to explore you know a professional
route
man my advice would say is like
stay true to yourself you know I mean
stay hungry stay humble I uh don't put a
date on succession you know what I mean
and don't don't don't do things out of
expectation you know I mean in like you
know just grind like hard work never
goes unnoticed you know I mean I feel
like I've been on both sides of it you
know what I mean just like
like dreaming about that time to come
and like comparing myself to people and
I had to like get out of that like state
of mind just be like yo just like stay
on your own lane stay true to yourself
and just grind yeah like people will
notice you know what I mean people will
notice the hard work and I was blessed
to have people around me that like
helped me you know stay on my toes about
that too and so yeah just keeping your
head down man be confident you know I
mean and just believe you know I mean
there's no limit on dreaming and there's
no limit on like what you can do so you
know Scott Scott I always say sky ain't
the limit people say sky's the limit I
say sky ain't the limit you know because
you could dream beyond that and just
take whatever you want to the next level
so